THIS IS THE ACCOMPLISHED LONG-DISTANCE SWIMMER, BEN LECOMTE,
JUST A FEW DAYS INTO THE MOST GRUELING
AND EXCITING SWIM OF HIS LIFE.
FOR EIGHT HOURS A DAY, BEN IS CHIPPING AWAY AT
MORE THAN 5,000 MILES OF PACIFIC OCEAN
THAT LIE AHEAD OF HIM.
HIS TRANS-PACIFIC SWIM IS NOT ONLY
MOTIVATED BY ADVENTURE
BUT ALSO BY A DESIRE TO RESEARCH
AND PRESERVE THE OCEAN.
Paul: What’s very specific with our situation,
with our expedition, is the scope of it.
It has never been done to have that much data
from one end of the ocean to the other.
JOINING BEN IS HIS NEPHEW AND EXPEDITION PROJECT MANAGER, PAUL LECOMTE.
Paul: All good, Ben?
PAUL IS PART OF THE 8-PERSON CREW
ONBOARD THE 20-METER SHIP, SEEKER.
AND THIS IS WHERE BEN AND THE CREW ARE LIVING
AND WORKING FOR THE NEXT 6-8 MONTHS.
WHILE ASSISTING BEN IN HIS SWIM, THEY WILL
ALSO BE COLLECTING DATA THAT WILL PROVIDE
AN IMPORTANT DEPICTION OF OCEAN HEALTH,
BY TRACKING MICROPLASTICS,
MONITORING PLANKTON,
AND EVEN COLLECTING AUDIO.
Paul: The purpose of the hydrophone is to
record all the life around us during the crossing
and to create the first soundscape
of the Pacific Ocean.
[dolphin clicks]
Maria: 25 meters.
Paul: Oh, yeah, the clicking.
Maria: Yeah?!
Paul: Insane!
BEN IS ALSO THE SUBJECT OF SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH,
WITH DATA BEING COLLECTED
ON HIS GUT MICROBIOME, HIS HEART, AND HIS MENTAL HEALTH.
BEN: The fact that I'm exercising so many
hours per day in a low-gravity environment...
What type of impact it will have on my
heart and my body, also the pressure of my eyes?
So anybody can use it as a way
to learn more about their field... the more the better.
PREPARATION BEGAN SEVEN YEARS AGO, AS BASELINE MEDICAL TESTS, INCLUDING MRIS,
BONE DENSITY SCANS, AND ECHOCARDIOGRAMS WERE CONDUCTED ON BEN AND STUDIED.
MEDICS ONBOARD, INCLUDING MAKS ROMEIJIN, WILL
OVERSEE BEN'S CARE AND ANY TESTING.
Maks: We have an onshore team of doctors who
advises us and who are accessible 24/7 for us.
So everything, what we do as a medic, is
a combination of us with them.
Maks: You can hear him screaming through his
snorkel, it's because the pain of his shoulder,
there's a lot of wetsuit rash and it's getting
sore, and it's open because it's salt water.
TO PROTECT BOTH HIS BODY AND MIND DURING THIS
SUPERHUMAN FEAT, A ROUTINE WAS DEVELOPED
WITH HIS CREW AND OUTSIDE PROFESSIONALS.
Maks: Good luck.
Paul: We've been talking to astronauts, we've been talking to people that were in this kind of environment
solitary, for a long time, and they told us
that routine is everything.
So, we have a very precise planning
of the day.
Ben wakes up, he has two hours of preparation, wetsuit, eating, doing all the medical checks.
We put Ben in the water
and we start the swim.
Every half hour, we have a check with the
swimmer, wants to drink, he wants to eat.
We have a check between the boat and the dinghy
Ty: Disco, this is Seeker.
...and at the same time, on the boat, we have
all the science protocols
happening for the 8 hours.
BEN HAS COMPLETED LONG-DISTANCE SWIMS THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE,
INCLUDING THE ATLANTIC OCEAN IN 1998.
THAT TIME, BEN WAS SWIMMING FOR
CANCER AWARENESS AND RESEARCH.
THIS TIME, HE’S HOPING FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
CHANGE — SO THAT WE CAN PRESERVE OUR OCEAN
FOR THE FUTURE.
Ben: It has a bigger purpose.
It's, for me, much more important to do The Swim and bring attention to the ocean
than just doing a swim because I love swimming
and I'm passionate about it.
Right now it's being carried on for other
generations, and for my kids.
I look at them very closely every time, because
I know that it's going to be
very important to them.
BE SURE TO VISIT SEEKER.COM/THESWIM TO READ DAILY UPDATES FROM BEN LECOMTE,
TRACK HIS PROGRESS IN REAL-TIME,
AND WATCH MORE VIDEOS ABOUT THE SCIENCE HAPPENING ONBOARD SEEKER.
CLICK HERE FOR THIS NEXT EPISODE, AND DON'T FORGET TO SUBSCRIBE.
THANKS FOR WATCHING.